y'all gonna end up unemployed riding
around in this pilot jump you're welcome
to all 2:16 man I'll sit in the back of
the plus you have identification on NASA
no idea they are there quite a few women
working in the space program at least I
can do is give you an escort three Negro
women are chasing a white police officer
down the highway in 1961 that is a
god-ordained miracle 14 days astronaut
will be here for training and we're
shooting a human from this space and
it's never been done before with the
launch of the Russian spy satellite
president is demanding an immediate
response a test we need the computer
care there is the gal for that she can
handle any numbers you put in this is
about amending the math because without
her we're not going anywhere
yes that's John Glenn what do you guys
do for NASA calculate you involved in
landing site how could you be other than
these white men this equal rights I have
the right to stand fine in Africa if you
like named would you wish to be an
engineer I wouldn't have to
I'd already be one I don't know if I can
keep up in that room just make that
pencil move as fast as your mind is
you've been gone for 300 hours I felt
like it too me too
Colonel Glenn launches in a few weeks we
don't have the man figured out there's
no protocol for women attending there's
no protocol for man circling the Earth
either sir every time we have a chance
to get ahead they move to finish up I
need to be in that room hearing what you
hear but then these walls makes yours
you sir you are the boss you just have
to act like one sir I'll get there
together we don't get there at all fight
of our lives people
my gals are ready we can do the work
more than 50 million Americans watching
I got a warning light go find Catherine
there's a real fireball outside it's
getting a little hot in here
I had no idea they heard what a few
women working in the space program space
group needs a computer yeah there is